it's taken more than a year and cost
dozens of lives to get to here the
appointment of somalia's new parliament
[Music]
about 250 mps and 50 senators have been
sworn in in a ceremony in the capital
mogadishu today is a great day and we
hope that this will
be
an opportunity for somalis in general
and also for the somali government
this man the prime minister mohammed
hussein roble has been in charge of the
process his supporters say he managed to
make it happen against stiff resistance
he's been at odds with the president
muhammad abdullahi farmaja was seeking
another term but didn't attend the
swearing-in ceremony
farmageo's critics and opponents say
he's been stalling the process to try
and stay in power
most somalis didn't get to vote clan
representatives selected mps in a series
of closed-door meetings
everyone involved says buying of votes
is widespread
the new mps are due to elect the next
president in the coming weeks
farmageo had promised to organise
elections where all somalis get to vote
but he didn't fulfill his pledge
the whole process has been widely
criticized it's indirect selection that
actually brought race to the bottom
selection process that lacks integrity
and credibility
so unless there is a strong strong rule
of law and election law uh somalia will
be in this uh what we've seen for the
past few months and the last year is
absolutely unacceptable and not to be
repeated again
a handful of seats in parliament remain
open after electoral officials nullified
their selection processes over
irregularities
mortars were fired towards mogadishu's
green zone as the other mps were
preparing to be sworn in inside
the armed group al-shabab is opposed to
the government and said it would target
the elections
it claimed responsibility for this
attack in the city of
last month that killed an mp and another
parliamentary candidate as well as
several other attacks
factions of the army fought the police
in mogadishu last year when yet another
election delay was announced and
president farmageo tried to extend his
term in office
somalis are now waiting to find out who
will be elected the next president and
if there'll be more bloodshed before
somalia has a new government malcolm
webb al jazeera